whenever I visit a new country it's a  little tradition I have I like to  promote the local beer it's kind of a  selfless act actually it's not because  I'm trying to get free beer and the beer  here is prestige regime you work with  prestige yes this is important to the  Haitian economy is it not absolutely  largest foreign direct investment here  in Haiti I want to help Haiti as much as  I can so I thought if you don't mind I  would shoot a quick improvised  commercial for prestige and we start by  toasting man hey Conan O'Brien here when  I'm in Haiti and I'm hanging out with an  attractive woman who's pretending to  find me funny  I drink prestige beer it's the beer to  have in Haiti if it's not prestige then  shut up Christie we drink yes and then  if you don't mind just turn to camera  and say he's hot he's hot sexy and funny  as hell  [Applause]